nous sommes à la journée à des
associations ESTACA à mes côtés
Catherine qui est présente ce jeudi 16
mars pour cette journée un petit peu
particulière ici à l'ESTACA c'est une
grande première Catherine tout à fait
c'est l'idée c'est de présenter les
projets associatifs assez variés comme
vous pouvez le voir qui ont lieu à
l'ESTACA aux partenaire pour les
associations de manière à ce qu'elle
puisse donner la visibilité aux
entreprises qui les connaissent pas
forcément et éventuellement trouver des
sponsors c'est un petit peu à l'essence
même de l'ESTACA c'est important de
attirer de nouveaux sponsors pour
pouvoir développer des projets peut-être
encore plus gros et plus important alors
tout à fait vous allez le voir ils ont
quand même développé des projets qui
participent à des compétitions donc
c'est des projets technologiques qui
nécessitent évidemment des budgets assez
importants donc c'est important qu'ils
aient des sponsors suffisants pour
pouvoir développer les technologies
qu'il souhaite et innover qu'est-ce
qu'on retrouve par exemple on voit qu'il
y a des projets quand même assez on a vu
R2D2 il y a quelques instants
Droid qui a été créé par les élèves il y
a aussi des mécaniques ici qu'est-ce
qu'on peut retrouver alors on trouve des
projets qui reflètent un petit peu les
différentes filières de l'école c'est à
dire vous avez des projets en automobile
alors par exemple le véhicule de la
énergétique de la pv3e ou le véhicule
qui concourt à la formulation chaque
année on trouve des projets plutôt dans
le domaine naval on trouve des projets
spatiaux c'est à dire qu'on a des
étudiants qui conçoivent et construisent
des fusées qui vont décoller chaque
année dans le cadre d'une compétition
étudiante organisée par le CNES on a des
projets côté ferroviaires bien sûr on a
des projets comme vous l'avez dû vu du
côté de tout ce qui est robotique voilà
donc ça couvre l'ensemble des filières
qui sont présentes à l'ESTACA ces
associations c'est vraiment très
important pour les stackards alors pour
nous c'est essentiel parce que tout ce
qui se passe sur les bancs de l'école
évidemment c'est important mais toutes
les compétences qui sont acquises dans
un cadre associatif c'est tout à fait
formateur aussi sur dans le cadre
associatif on apprend à gérer un projet
on apprend à gérer un budget on apprend
à travailler en équipe on apprend à
avoir des délais à respecter des cahiers
des charges et tout ça c'est aussi très
formateur et les entreprises qui
recrutent nos diplômés nous le disent
très régulièrement pour eux tout ce
qu'ils ont appris à l'école dans le
cadre académique c'est évidemment très
bien mais c'est un vrai plus que d'avoir
des compétences acquises dans des
projets concrets comme dans le cas des
projets associatifs si je comprends bien
il y a l'école et après il y a les
associations il y a quand même l'école
qui est très importante bien sûr et il
faut savoir que même dans le cadre
académique certains projets proposés par
les associations peuvent entrer dans le
garde du cursus c'est-à-dire que il y a
des études technologiques qui sont
intégrés à l'intérieur même du programme
académique donc voilà donc c'est c'est
vraiment pour nous c'est un tout et
c'est pour ça que l'école encourage
vraiment les étudiants à s'investir dans
la vie associative parce qu'on sait que
c'est une vraie valeur ajoutée tous les
élèves présents ici à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux font partie d'une
association alors tout se peut être
timing très grande majorité à peu près
ou pas
vous donner un pourcentage mais vraiment
une majorité d'étudiants sont investis
dans les associations étudiantes est-ce
qu'il y a un projet en particulier qui
vous fascine
alors il y en a beaucoup qui me fascine
on est on est en face de de la
formulation voilà on peut peut-être
parler de des stacca formulatif qui a un
nouveau projet qui a été présenté la
semaine dernière justement dévoilé le
nouveau véhicule a été dévoilé eux ils
participent chaque année à une grande
compétition internationale qui s'appelle
la Formula Student voilà donc ça c'est
un projet très innovant on a ezo et ses
fusées qui sont là c'est également voilà
des étudiants qui travaillent toute
l'année pour concevoir leur fusée qui
vont décoller dans le cadre des
campagnes organisées par le CNES on
aille de Douai ce qui est une
association alors sur un une un secteur
qui est moins attractif qui est le
ferroviaire mais qui développe des très
très beaux projets qui montent des
conférences en alpdg de la SNCF qui va
passer la semaine dernière sur leur
invitation voilà donc il y a beaucoup
d'associations alors je vois le cercle
aéronautique aussi dont on n'a pas parlé
qui est une association dans le domaine
aéronautique qui organise de la
formation pour les étudiants qui veulent
voilà se former et pour devenir pilote
amateur ils organisent des rallies
aériens des visites d'entreprises donc
il y a vraiment plein d'associations
dans des domaines très variés qui
méritent notre admiration toutes les
personnes qui ont des idées peuvent
venir les stacs si je comprends bien ils
peuvent venir à l'ESTACA développer
leurs idées ils sont bienvenus voilà
romain qui est responsable Fédération
des associations
nous sommes maintenant avec Romain qui
va tout nous expliquer sur cette
association qui est juste derrière moi
c'est Enzo alors Enzo qu'est-ce que
c'est Romain alors les os c'est l'ESTACA
space odyssey c'est une association qui
représente la pierre spatiale de l'école
et son but c'est de travailler sur des
projets techniques qui font grandir les
élèves en termes de compétences dans ce
secteur là et donc leur projet phare qui
s'appelle le SL les staccas Space
launcher leur but final en 2025 c'est de
lancer une fusée à 30 km de hauteur ça
c'est novateur ou pas comme association
bah c'est clair comme association
étudiante réalisée de tels c'est
vraiment assez novateur il y a d'autres
écoles d'autres université qui font des
projets de la même ampleur mais des
autres positionnent clairement comme une
grosse association dans le secteur
étudiant à peu près combien de personnes
à peu près dans cette association les
eaux je dirais qu'ils sont quasiment 200
voilà et comment ça se passe
concrètement quand on est étudiant ici
on va tout de suite en philosociations
dès que l'école est terminée mais on
voit que ce sont quand même des projets
gigantesques ça prend énormément de
temps
c'est vrai qu'elle est Staka il y a un
engagement dans les associations qui est
très fort on a plus de deux étudiants
sur 3 qui participent à des projets
entre la première et la quatrième année
donc les étudiants sont globalement
enfin très investis et pas du temps en
dehors des cours et les week-ends
passent leur temps là-bas pour
développer les différents projets et
qu'est-ce qui fait que ça plaît
justement de travailler dans une
association vous d'ailleurs vous avez
été à membre d'une association bah je
pense qu'il plaît à l'ESTACA et c'est
pour ça qu'il y a autant d'aspilations
c'est que l'environnement est enfin très
propice il y a constamment des
événements et on se sent vraiment
toutes ces étudiants font partie d'une
équipe et je pense c'est ça qui est
motivé à travailler encore et encore et
quels sont les retours
extérieurs sur les associations
on a juste à voir le nombre de
partenaires de la plupart des
associations et les budgets qui sont mis
en jeu pour les différents projets pour
comprendre que
les associations à l'ESTACA c'est
quelque chose de vraiment majeur et
important et
comme je l'ai dit le nombre de
partenaires c'est c'est quand même assez
important les eaux par exemple c'est
énormément de partenaire j'imagine
autour d'un projet comme celui-là c'est
énormément de partenaire et même des
gros partenaires comme Ariane comme
différents sites de lancement parce que
c'est vrai que ça demande des
infrastructures qui sont très grosses
pour lancer des fusées et donc
il se déplace au new space ou à l'Europe
par exemple pour pour lancer leur modèle
petite précision il faut obligatoirement
faire partie de l'ESTACA pour faire
partie d'une association on est d'accord
ça dépend des associations et de manière
générale non mais c'est vrai que pour
réaliser les projets et pour bénéficier
enfin de tous les avantages et de toutes
les conférences et de tout ce qui se
passe faut faire partie des steaks et
pour avoir plus de renseignements
j'imagine qu'il y a tout sur le site
internet de l'ESTACA il y a beaucoup
d'informations sur le site internet de
l'ESTACA chaque association a son site
internet derrière donc si vous voulez
vous renseigner sur les associations en
général allez sur le site de l'estaca.1
fr voilà donc deux tiers des étudiants
de l'ESTACA font partie des associations
et ils espèrent avoir de nombreux
partenaires dans les prochaines années